I guess not all pixels cost the same to paint on the page. I
should really pay attention to what affects
I'm applying and everything else I'm doing.
>> Yep, exactly. Although remember the cardinal rule of web performance?
>> Let me think measure first then optimize.
>> Exactly, let's take a look.
Okay, we're looking at a trace of the New York Times
homepage. We want to look at Paint events, so let's filter out
the rest. As you can see, there are many Paint events,
but let me show you a handy trick. We can select a
time range that we want to show on the timeline by
dragging the sliders at the top here. Notice that as we do
this, the pie chart on the bottom is updated with the total
times. Yep, and also while we're here let's identify some expensive things.
For example, this one took eight milliseconds.
>> Hmm. So, let me see. We said that anytime we want to update the render tree,
there's a good chance we'll have to run layout,
and I'm guessing the same applies for painting, right?
>> That's right. The browser applies a lot
of smarts and tried to repaint the minimum required
area. But really it all depends on what kind
of updates are being applied to the render tree.